hello hello there Steve Kaufman I've had
some questions about two issues that I'm
going to try to combine in one video
here one question was what do I think of
Esperanto and the other question had to
do with French immersion and to some
extent the two in my mind are a little
bit related and I'll explain why but I
may not get it all done within the ten
minutes
Esperanto we have to understand that in
learning and language the number one
factor is how motivated the learner is
to learn the language so I am NOT very
motivated to learn Esperanto but that
doesn't mean that other people aren't
and people should be able to learn the
language that they want to learn and you
know we would love at link one day to
offer Esperanto and Latin and ancient
Greek or you know Aboriginal languages
or any language that people want to
learn as long as there are people who
can speak that language and who can
record themselves using that language
and if we can get transcripts we will
use it at link it's entirely up to
people what they want to learn that's
the because if people are strongly
motivated to learn something they will
learn now why am I not motivated to
learn Esperanto because every time I
learn a language I discover a whole
world I mean I was today I had lunch in
a inexpensive Persian restaurant here in
West Vancouver and I thought then they
had that Persian television on and
Persian music and Persian you know
Arabic script running across the screen
and I thought boy I'd love to would be
neat to to understand Persian because
with every language you learn you learn
about the culture you learn something
about their customs you learn something
about their history you learn something
about how they view the world it's not
just the language you learn and the
languages that we have today are the
result of sort of nach
evolution over thousands and thousands
of years I mean the language that we
speak English or Chinese or Swahili or
something is connected back to languages
that existed a hundred thousand years
ago in in some ways that we don't really
know so I to me language is a living
thing and very much connected with the
culture of the people who speak that
language today Russian I I love my
Russian law of novels I love listening
to my Russians my the people that I
listen to argue on my favorite Russian
website are chemists Greek Chinese
culture ji was the other day I was at a
Japanese restaurant and experiencing
their culture and because I speak the
language I feel much more that I can
participate in that culture then if I
went to you know then at the Persian
restaurant where I don't speak the
language so to me if I'm gonna go to the
trouble of learning a language I want to
participate in this culture living
culture Esperanto doesn't offer any of
that
I mean Latin I'm almost more motivated
to learn Latin because Latin is
connected to you know all of the romance
languages that we have today so
Esperanto was created by some idealist
some intellectuals who arbitrarily
decided that they were gonna take this
that and the other from certain
languages of course they didn't include
Asian languages that include African
languages and that this was going to
become an international language so to
me it's artificial so I can't get myself
motivated to learn it but if someone
else for whatever reason wants to learn
Esperanto
please go to it I you know in all of my
life in all the countries that I have
been to I have yet to meet one person
who speaks Esperanto so I'm not very
motivated but I know that there's a
whole community of people who are very
you know enthusiastic and fine and and
one day maybe we'll have Esperanto at
length and and so where this connects
with with the issue of French Immersion
is that in learning a language it's the
key is the learner it's not the teacher
it's the learner and the learner has to
be motivated that's essential and so
therefore the more the learner should
have choice what tends to happen in our
schools is that the initiative is
entirely with the teacher and as long as
the initiative is with the teacher the
learning is not very effective
so with French immersion which is very
popular in Canada because French is one
of our two official languages and so the
public school system offers the
opportunity for english-speaking
children to take all of their schooling
in French so they study their you know
social studies history that are
mathematically studied all in French and
so they have an artificial environment
where they're forbidden to speak English
at school even though all the kids are
English speaking when they go home they
speak English and my grandson was
telling me because my grandchildren go
to French immersion but saying that that
some teacher instituted this system
where everyone had tickets and if they
heard someone speak English they could
get a ticket from that person and the
idea was to collect as many tickets as
possible so you're basically encouraging
people the children to tell on each
other to snitch on each other what a
ridiculous idea so you know and and it's
interesting with French Immersion I have
met
I mean French immersion students end up
speaking French better than most kids
who go through the regular system
because in the regular school system
they teach French so poorly that most
people hate it and very few people speak
it in immersion most people end up
speaking it after a fashion not very
many of them end up truly bilingual
because they spent most of those years
in immersion speaking French poorly with
other non-native speakers being their
fellow students it's interesting that we
have in Canada we have early immersion
from great one and late immersion from
grade seven I think or six the late
immersion kids end up speaking just as
well
as the early immersion kids and I am of
the belief that if we had a totally
different approach to language learning
if we let kids learn any line on any but
a variety of languages as kit as in
their first or second or third or fourth
year that say when they're 12 or 13 if
they decided now I want to learn French
now I wanna learn Spanish they would
learn it very quickly so in other words
if we have a sit where if the motivation
is there the kids will learn very very
quickly they don't have to suffer
through 12 years of doing geography and
history and French which after all is a
foreign language for them and I can't
help but believe that they would be more
interested in the subject if they could
read it in their own language so there
is a sacrifice so if we allowed kids if
the first and I've mentioned this before
the first three four years five years of
schooling were devoted to allowing the
kids to try any language you know you
don't have to have a teacher of Chinese
or or or Spanish or French there's so
many resources available on the Internet
the teacher just has to show the
learners where they can find audio-video
books help them use the resources that
are on the internet so that they can
read through a text that's in a
different language help them in a
variety of ways don't force them to
study this language or that language and
then let them decide what they want to
learn now of course for political
reasons in countries like Canada we that
you have to learn French but in fact 99%
of English speakers are made are 95% and
are not speaking French so we don't
really achieve anything we're far better
to say do you want to learn Spanish
learn Spanish
why learn Chinese learn Chinese and then
at some point if you want to work for
the federal government are you going to
learn French and if you've learned
another language it won't be so
difficult to learn French so if I
summarize all of this what I'm saying is
that the approach to language learning
should be that it should be fun we want
to focus on all the different ways that
we can motivate people that if we can
get people to enjoy their language
learning have fun with it don't worry
about making mistakes that in
that kind of an environment we we train
people to learn and if people have
learned how to learn when they really
need to learn something they can learn
it very very quickly if they haven't
learned how to learn then you know they
can just waste time year after year
after year they can pass the French test
they can do all this than that and the
end up not speaking so Esperanto if you
want Esperanto go for it it's not
something that I'm motivated to learn
for the reasons that I explained it's
not spoken by any culture it's not it
doesn't have any history behind it it I
can't go to someplace and sit down at a
bar and have the person beside me you
know strike up a conversation in
Esperanto and French Immersion to me is
a little artificial again it's it's
something that's imposed on the kids and
I think language is something that we
could allow more freedom for people to
study what they want allow them to have
fun with it and if they develop the
ability to learn languages they will
learn when they want to bye for now